Hey everyone, Ryan here, and welcome back to our oral medicine series.
This video will be all about INR, bleeding, clotting, and all of the concepts that go along
with those.
So why is this important for us to discuss?
Well beyond being a big topic on the board exam, a lot of procedures in dentistry cause
bleeding, and usually that's not a problem, but in patients whose ability to control bleeding
has been changed due to certain drugs or diseases, these same procedures could be potentially
disastrous.
So appropriate identification of these patients, and appropriate management of them while
in the dental chair, will help mitigate those risks.
So in this context, patients will fall somewhere on this spectrum between bleeding and clotting.
If they're on blood thinners, they're going to tend toward bleeding, and if they're older,
had a major surgery or hospitalization or sedentary or immobile, they're going to
tend toward clotting.
So just keep this spectrum in mind throughout this video.
Before we can get to INR, platelets, and all of that, first we need to talk about how clotting
happens.
So let's say you get cut, and the blood vessels in that area are also injured as a result.
Now to prevent your blood from just spilling out uncontrollably, there are four phases
of the hemostasis process.
This means stopping blood.
The first phase is vascular, this involves vasoconstriction, where the affected vessels
physically contract.
Next is the platelet phase, which involves a platelet plug, where platelets rush to the
area, and this is considered primary hemostasis.
Next the third phase is coagulation, which involves a fibrin clot.
It's this mesh of fibrin material that basically holds the platelet plug together.
This is considered secondary hemostasis.
And then finally we have the fibrinolytic phase.
It involves plasmin, which is an enzyme in blood, that cuts the fibrin mesh and dissolves
the clot after it's done its job.
So primary hemostasis is all about platelets, secondary hemostasis is all about coagulation.
Note that these are two entirely different things.
So hemostasis as a whole relies on the proper function of blood vessels, platelets, and
coagulation factors, all of which we'll talk more about.
Bleeding disorders can be inherited via genetics or acquired via the environment.
And there are hundreds of bleeding disorders that we could talk about, but of course that
would take a really long time, and it's just beyond the scope of the dental board exam.
So I'm going to focus on only the important ones.
The vascular phase, as we just talked about, is our first step in hemostasis.
So we will properly start with vascular wall defects.
Thankfully, this is not a big deal for dental care, and patients with these defects rarely
will have a severe bleeding episode after a tooth extraction.
Marfan syndrome and Ehlers-Danlos syndrome affect connective tissue, which in turn affects
the vascular wall.
And then Ossler-Weberrendu syndrome, also known as hereditary hemorrhagic telangectasia,
affects blood vessels more directly.
So all three of these can compromise the integrity of the vascular wall, impacting that first
phase of hemostasis.
Management of these patients includes coordination with their hematologist, minimally invasive
dentistry with good surgical technique, local hemostatic measures, which I'll talk more
about in depth later in the video, and avoiding aspirin and other nonsteroidal anti-inflammatory
drugs.
We'll talk more about those later as well.
The platelet pathway is the next phase of hemostasis, so let's talk about that one next.
So how this works is we have an endothelium layer that lines the inside of each blood vessel,
and endothelial damage causes the release of von Willebrande factor, VWF for short, from
the endothelium, which then attaches to circulating platelets in purple, via glycoprotein 1B.
So at this stage, the platelets are now adhered to the endothelium via this glycoprotein and
von Willebrande factor.
So that's the first step, adhesion.
Next comes activation.
So binding to the von Willebrande factor really excites these platelets, and so they get activated
and grow these extensions.
Not only that, but they secrete activators that include thromboxane A2 and adenosine
diphosphate ADP, which further activate other circulating platelets, so it's this positive
feedback loop effect.
And now that the platelets are activated, they begin to express glycoprotein 2B/3A.
Fibrinogen is also floating through the bloodstream and sticks to this glycoprotein complex like
Velcro, and since Velcro is super sticky, the platelets begin sticking to each other,
which is called aggregation.
So keep in mind that as more and more platelets aggregate to each other, they also get activated,
releasing more thromboxane A2 and ADP, and the positive feedback loop continues.
Now I remember this step because aggregation, the word, has two of the same letters right
next to each other to symbolize two platelets sticking to each other.
The end result of primary hemostasis is a platelet plug composed of a whole bunch of
platelets, fibrinogen and tethered to the endothelium via von Willebrand factor.
So that's how it's supposed to work, but how can it go wrong?
Well we have what's known as von Willebrand disease, which causes a deficiency in von
Willebrand factor, affecting the ability of platelets to adhere to the vessel wall.
Now it's the most common congenital bleeding disorder affecting about 1% of the population.
So without that lime green starburst here, that initial step of adhesion cannot happen.
And we didn't talk about this, but von Willebrand factor also acts as a carrier for coagulation
factor 8.
We'll get more into coagulation a little bit later, but just keep that in the back of your
head that this condition affects both platelets and coagulation.
So we'll see it again real soon.
And we also have thrombocytopenia, this refers to low platelets.
It's not technically a diagnosis, but rather the result of another disease or etiology.
It can be drug induced, like drugs that are toxic to the bone marrow, or immune mediated.
So it could be related to leukemia or HIV, for example.
So a normal platelet count is somewhere between 150,000 to 450,000 platelets per microliter
of blood.
Less than this is considered thrombocytopenia.
You have increased clinical bleeding when that's below 50,000, and then you can have
spontaneous bleeding once that number hits below 20,000.
And this is an example of what a platelet looks like compared to a bunch of red blood
cells.
The platelet pathway can also be disrupted on purpose.
So patients may be treated with anti-platelet medications if they had a history of heart
attack or placement of a coronary artery stent in order to prevent formation of unwanted
platelet plugs.
So, these medications are designed to interfere with one of those three A's, adhesion, activation,
or aggregation.
So aspirin inhibits the Cox-1 enzyme to prevent synthesis of thromboxane A2 in order
to block activation, and this is irreversible.
Now other NSAIDs, like ibuprofen, do the same thing but are reversible.
Clopidogrel is a drug that competes with ADP at its receptor to block activation.
And F6imab binds to the glycoprotein 2B3A complex to block aggregation.
I remember this one because A and B are right next to each other in the drug name and so
are B and A in this glycoprotein complex.
So these are three examples of drugs that can disrupt the platelet pathway.
And then we come to platelet testing.
So why is this done?
Well, a hematologist may want to run one of these tests in order to diagnose von Willebrand
disease, or to check the status of thrombocytopenia, or maybe even to see how anti-platelet medications
are working to name some examples.
And next we have to ask, well how do we test for something like platelet number, quantity,
or platelet function, quality?
Well we can order a platelet count, that's where you have a blood sample taken, and as
part of a complete blood count, the concentration of platelets in the blood sample is counted.
So thrombocytopenia would be confirmed if platelets are low, again it tends to be common
in HIV or leukemia patients.
So this would of course be talking about quantity of platelets.
An IV bleeding test involves making a cut in the patient's arm and then timing how long
it takes for bleeding to stop.
It has been used to screen for disorders of platelet function, like in the use of chronic
NSAIDs, and platelet number, again thrombocytopenia, so it can be used to test either quantity
or quality.
Unfortunately, it's rather unreliable and no longer used.
The peripheral blood smear involves looking under a microscope to see whether the cells
look morphologically normal or not, so this will tell you about platelet quality.
The platelet aggregation test checks how well your platelets clump together to form that
plug.
And then the platelet function analyzer, the PFA 100, is an instrument that measures platelet
dependent coagulation under flow conditions, so it's better than the bleeding test but
unfortunately it's not sensitive enough to rule out mild bleeding disorders, so neither
the bleeding test nor PFA 100 are recommended as screening tests to be used by dentists.
So patient considerations for platelet disorders are the same as they were for those vascular
wall defects.
And now we come to phase three of hemostasis, coagulation.
So this is a table I put together for each coagulation factor in the coagulation cascade
or pathway and where they're found in the body.
We don't have time to talk through all of this but you can always refer back to it later.
I thought it might be helpful to just have all this information clearly laid out.
And note that a vast majority of these coagulation factors are synthesized in the liver.
So here I have listed the factors involved by number.
So how this works is each factor activates the factor below it.
So for example, 12 would make 11, factor 11 turn into factor 11A, A for activated.
And 11A would in turn make nine turn into nine A and so on.
So you'd go down the cascade in that fashion.
I don't have the A's listed because it just makes things way more complicated and busy
than they have to be.
So let's actually start at the bottom or the end of this coagulation cascade.
So the clot is obviously the goal here and factor one is at the end of this cascade.
And it's aptly named because it is number one.
It's the most important factor of this pathway.
If you go back to our table, one is fibrinogen.
And fibrinogen may sound familiar.
Well that's because fibrinogen is also in the platelet pathway.
It was the Velcro responsible for aggregation of platelets to each other.
So you may be wondering how does the body know where to activate this coagulation cascade?
The answer is at the giant plug of platelets coated in a mesh of fibrinogen, the substrate
for this entire cascade.
And this is why our blood isn't just one giant clot.
It only clots where we already have a platelet plug.
Very very cool.
So we have two separate pathways to start.
We have intrinsic in red and extrinsic in green that converge on the common pathway in blue,
which is shared between the two.
And lastly for memory sake, factor ten or the roman numeral X is in the central location
of all of these pathways because of course, if you've ever looked for berry treasure,
X marks the spot.
So let's start with the extrinsic pathway.
This is outside the blood vessel.
It's triggered by external trauma that causes blood to escape its vessel.
And the damaged endothelium expresses tissue factor or thromboplastin.
That's just another name for factor three, which jump starts this pathway.
It's usually quicker than the intrinsic pathway as a side note.
So three activates seven, which activates ten, and now we're back in the common pathway.
So ten works with five to activate factor two, which activates factor one and thirteen.
You can remember this because one is the smallest and thirteen is the largest number.
So those two work together.
Now we've talked at length about factor one, but now let's spend some time on factor two
because well, it's the second most important factor in this list.
It's called prothrombin.
And when activated to factor two A, it becomes thrombin, which activates a bunch of other
factors.
It actually activates five and seven and eight, eleven, and even thirteen.
Providing a positive feedback loop and even activating the intrinsic pathway up here.
So when factor two gets involved, it's really speeding everything up.
Now let's talk about the intrinsic pathway.
This is inside the blood vessel, and you may be wondering, well, what's the deal with
factor twelve, also called hagmin factor?
It's not one of the ones activated by thrombin.
Remember, thrombin only reached up to factor eleven.
So what is factor twelve doing way up here?
And how does it get activated initially?
Well, trauma can expose collagen on the inside of blood vessels, which activates factor twelve.
But it's not actually necessary for clotting to occur, because again, thrombin can start
this pathway from factor eleven, and then it goes from there.
What's nice is there is some order to this pathway.
We start with twelve, then go to eleven, we skip ten and go down to nine, which is next
to eight, and it lines up with seven over here.
So there's some order in terms of counting down with numbers right next to each other.
But of course, like with the platelet pathway, things can go wrong with the coagulation cascade.
So let's talk about some clotting factor defects.
So for inherited defects, we have, once again, as promised, Von Willebrand disease.
So remember, as I mentioned before, Von Willebrand disease not only messes up platelets, but it
also interferes with factor eight, so we have it on this slide as well.
Next we have to talk about another big disease, hemophilia, which comes from the Greek meaning
love to bleed.
Now these people have a hereditary condition where they bleed easily because they are deficient
in a certain clotting factor.
Hemophilia A is by far the most common of the three hemophilias here, and it's autosomal
X-linked recessive, therefore affecting mainly males.
Also if local anesthesia is necessary for a patient with hemophilia A, there is an eighty
percent chance that a patient with hemophilia A will develop a hematoma following an inferior
alveolar nerve block injection without prior factor eight infusion.
The hematoma could even be fatal if it accumulates in the media stinum and compromises the airway.
So bottom line, stick with local infiltrations only in the mandible for these patients.
So hemophilia A involves a deficiency in factor eight, A for eight, and then hemophilia B involves
a deficiency in factor nine, hemophilia C involves a deficiency in factor eleven.
And these two, you can remember go together, calling nine one one.
So that's how I remember those.
Also notice how all forms of hemophilia affect the intrinsic pathway.
We have eight nine and eleven, which are all right next to each other in that intrinsic
pathway.
So that can also help you remember those.
And then to finish off this list, we have two acquired disease processes.
So vitamin K deficiency is the most common of all acquired coagulation disorders.
Those two seven nine and ten are made in the liver and require vitamin K for their synthesis.
So that's why they're specifically impacted if vitamin K is low.
Liver dysfunction, like severe liver disease, can lead to deficiencies again in these vitamin
K dependent coagulation factors, two seven nine and ten.
I purposely listed some in number form and some in romanumeral form because they can
be listed in either form on the board exam.
So just get used to seeing them in both ways.
There are other disease processes that we can put on this list like chronic kidney disease
and autoimmune diseases, but these are the main ones that I wanted to cover that are
most likely to appear on your board exam.
Now just like with the platelet pathway, we have medications that can disrupt the coagulation
cascade on purpose.
So if you have someone who is a cloder and dangerously so, then one of these may be prescribed
for that reason.
Some examples include reducing the risk of heart attack or stroke, patients with atrial
fibrillation, prosthetic heart valves, history of deep venous thrombosis blood clots and
things like that.
Now the next point I want to make absolutely crystal clear, anti-coagulants are different
from anti-platelet medications that we talked about before because these drugs affect coagulation
not the platelet pathway.
For example, a ton of people refer to aspirin as an anti-coagulant, and that's not correct.
Aspirin inhibits platelet activation by blocking Cox-1 and thromboxian A2 synthesis.
Now while it is a blood thinner, aspirin does not affect the coagulation cascade at all,
and so it's not an anti-coagulant.
I threw out the category blood thinner, so both anti-platelets and anti-coagulants are
blood thinners, they make someone more likely to bleed.
Now here are the anti-coagulants.
So warfarin blocks reduction recycling of vitamin K, which means that, once again, those
factors that depend on vitamin K, 2, 7, 9, and 10 are hindered, which will definitely
mess with clotting.
Thrombin pulls thrombin and this thing called anti-thrombin together, which blocks factor
2 specifically.
Epixaban, or Eliquis, directly inhibits factor 10A, and then Dabogatran binds to thrombin,
which is factor 2A, at its active site, and inhibits it, so this is a direct thrombin
inhibitor, while the other three examples are indirect thrombin inhibitors.
Now like in the platelet section, there are tests that a hematologist can order to check
on how this coagulation cascade is working.
So let's talk about the activated partial thromboplastin time test first, or APTT.
This measures the number of seconds it takes for a clot to form in a sample of blood after
certain reagents are added to it.
It's used to check the intrinsic system and common pathway, so it's also the best single
screening test for coagulation disorders.
It's used to test Von Willebrand disease, hemophilia, among many others.
The normal range for this test is somewhere between 25 and 35 seconds.
A shorter time means they are more towards the clotting end of the spectrum.
A longer time means they are closer to the bleeding end of the spectrum.
And then we have the prothrombin time test, or PT test.
This one also measures how long it takes for a clot to form in a blood sample, but it's
used almost exclusively for patients on Warfarin and is used to derive the INR, which is the
international normalized ratio for a particular patient.
All INR is a normalized PT.
It's normalized for different lab materials from lab to lab.
And how to remember that they are for patients on Warfarin is because the last three letters
of the word Warfarin are INR, just in a different order.
So the normal range for this test is somewhere between 11 and 15 seconds.
The smaller the INR, that's indicating a clotter, the larger the INR that's indicating a bleeder.
And just as an aside, the factors in red here are those vitamin K dependent factors that
we talked about in this slide and this slide.
So just to help you remember two, seven, nine, and ten, the nice thing is they're all right
next to each other in that handy diagram.
Alright the moment you've all been waiting for, let's dive more into INR.
And this is a huge, huge part of the new board exam.
So first, for all patients taking Warfarin, there are some precautions that should be
taken.
We want to avoid aspirin and all other NSAIDs, which can make bleeding risk higher.
And we know now that's by messing with platelets.
So Tylenol with or without codeine is suggested for pain control instead.
We want to avoid metronidazol, erythromycin, and broad-spectrum antibiotics that can potentiate
the anti-coagulation effect of Warfarin.
Similarly, herbal supplements can make anti-coagulation more significant as well, can enhance the bleeding
for that patient.
Barbiturates and steroids actually antagonize the action of Warfarin.
So those should be avoided in order to prevent the INR from getting too low toward the clotting
side.
For Warfarin patients undergoing surgery, local hemostatic measures should be taken.
So this is what I was mentioning earlier on in the video.
And these involve compressive packing and dressing to physically stop bleeding, extra
sutures and primary closure over the surgical site were possible, a 4.8% tranexamic acid
mouthwash which promotes clotting and topical thrombin which does the same.
So clinical evidence suggests that the risk of bleeding out with a therapeutic INR is
very, very small.
In general, the risk of clotting outweighs the benefit.
In other words, it's better to stay on those medications that favor the propensity to bleed
rather than the propensity to clot without them which can be life threatening for certain
patients.
However, if a complex major oral surgery is planned where significant bleeding is likely,
only then would modification of Warfarin therapy with a medical consultation be potentially
necessary.
So where exactly do we make that threshold?
You might be wondering.
So for an INR between 2 and 3, this is actually a great therapeutic range for many conditions
like atrial fibrillation, deep venous thrombosis and pulmonary embolism.
Generally, there are no bleeding concerns for patients in this range.
And beyond the above considerations that we just talked about, you can proceed with
any dental treatment.
For an INR between 3 and 3.5, it may be desired for patients with a prosthetic heart valve,
but it's a bit high for major complex surgeries.
So if the patient is undergoing a simple minor oral surgery like a single tooth extraction,
you can continue with treatment with the above considerations.
But if it's a major oral surgery like a full arch extraction, then we want to defer treatment
and refer to their medical doctor about changing the Warfarin dose temporarily and then retesting
INR before proceeding with dental care.
Now if the INR is greater than 3.5, no matter what is planned, the dentist should refer the
patient to their doctor and request that the dosage be reduced to allow that INR to fall
within a healthier therapeutic range.
If the dose is reduced by the physician, it will take 3-5 days for the desired reduction
to occur.
The reduction should be confirmed by a new INR before the dental or surgical procedure,
which should be scheduled within 2 days after that new INR.
After the procedure is finished, and there are no complications in terms of bleeding
or infection, then the physician should be contacted to resume the usual Warfarin dose.
And at the end of the day, if you're ever unsure about any of these steps, consult with
the patient's hematologist to ensure a safe tooth extraction.
Lastly oral manifestations of people with any of the above that we just talked about, vascular
wall defects, platelet disorders, or coagulation issues.
So what we can see is easy or spontaneous gingerable bleeding.
Oral tissues like the soft palate, tongue, and buccomucosa may show these little peteciae
or maybe a larger echomoses, sometimes even you see jaundice, pallor, and ulcers.
And lastly, hemorthrosis of the TMJ, that's bleeding into the jaw joint.
This is a rare finding, but has been linked specifically to hemophilia.
Alright so that's it for this video guys, thank you so much for watching.
Please like this video if you enjoyed it and subscribe to this channel if you haven't
already for much more on dentistry.
If you'd like to support me, please check me out on my Patreon page.
And thank you to all of my patrons for their support.
You can unlock access to my video slides to take notes on them and practice questions
for the board exams, so go check that out, the link will be in the description below.
Thanks again for watching everyone, I'll see you in the next video.